hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to white knight not
even white knight it's a white knight
but it's not the white knight okay we're
we're almost fully immerged immersion
ated into the realm of insanity here
things are going very weird very quickly
and I'm not sure but as I mentioned in
the last one it's getting very cry of
fear esque up in this [ __ ]
which means that reality unravels at a
rather sadistic pace well hello can I
get that no I cannot get through here I
don't see an exit
they all look that way here we go wait a
minute this is different this is another
way around no this is the first way
around no this is the same way around no
this is a different way around what am i
doing where am I going
so confusing in here I can't see [ __ ]
but I feel like I'm gonna run out of
whoa okay that was the wrong way watch
vine step styie f off come on get me
back in her I'm a derpy derpy idiot I'm
just gonna wander around until I fall in
random black holes because if I fall
everybody knows that I could never
aha here we go I could never ever
recover as in oh haha I see that black
hole and gonna get me I'm not that
stupid I'm pretty dumb well I'm not that
dumb hahaha who does smart one now who's
your smarty smarty pants oh wait wait am
I going where am I going here
ah-ha-ha-ha-ha no key take a smorgasbord
of wood ring of reflections
does it give a +2 to intelligence ha +2
to treasure finding Wow reflections is
inscribed I'm up put it on yours it on
your finger you nincompoop
it was doing the ring okay what was your
point of his hat hey let me get this
note here after I searched inside him
they caught me while I was looking
inside his cabinet they found and took
my ring - my ring inscribed with their
memories if I don't have to ring to wear
a ring to wear why would I have fingers
and that's why he cut off his fingers
what what does that go really quiet it
got really quiet hi
what was that I don't like this I don't
like this I don't like it I don't like
it I'm out of here
I'm out of screw you and everything you
care about going down to one alright I
got a real bad feeling just as I was
coming out of that last place I haven't
surprised nothing bad happened I loved
her so much so much that I couldn't
breathe without her when they brought me
here they told me everything was gonna
be just fine like I would believe that
nonsense
they'll never understand me I know this
for sure yesterday he took my ring and
locked it away I should have hidden it
better it was my only memento let
memento left from her he said it was
part of the progress who said I want to
develop some progress
I just want my ring back my ring
inscribed with her reflection today I
did it I did it for you my love I took
the knife and searched inside him it was
not there I think I'll find it in his
cabinet he always was always locking his
cabinet it has to be in there this is
some sort of combonation
I don't have the combination yet but I
assume I'll find it down this rather
diabolical looking Holloway with all the
dead bodies loverly whoa hi dad not fair
that's Pyramid Head I know him
I know him I haven't even played a
Silent Hill game and I know him why is
he here he does both to be here
what is this insane asylum in Silent
Hill no dealio yes yeah open up okay so
I got a her okay do I have a herder oh
no no it didn't work
I'm so surprised that that didn't work
okay so there's gotta be some clues here
maybe with the dead bodies hello hello
okay if I look at via okay if I look at
these then every button is pressed
except for that one that one there's
eight patients eight buttons eight
buttons hmm
but which direction is up so blah blah
and then not blah blah blah I don't know
maybe a look at this way blah blah blah
blah and blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah no and let's try that blah blah
blah see blah da no blah blah blah blah
nope
I see let's try the blah blah blah and
then blah blah blah no oh you know how
to reset it what am I do
whatever do I might be here a while ah
okay her dear baby number six go to
South and eat dinner all dinner whoa
it's not really much of a clue here I
mean there's obviously two by or the
bodies here and I'm sure this has
directly correlates to the numbers or
the buttons on the fridge eyo here but I
don't know where in which way they
correlate or how to get the numbers in
appropriately maybe it's sort of like
this
this means top has been nothing and this
means bottom and this means both I don't
know
okay so na ba ba na ba burn ah okay so
burn no pepper
na BRR BRR BRR ya know I'm gonna be here
for ages alright screw this I'm going
back upstairs I could try to brute-force
it but I don't feel like it okay so now
we're back here maybe if I put the ring
in this guy's hand put the ring on the
hand yep that looks good so uh let me in
there gave you a ring back what you
gonna do about that for me yeah helped
out there uh do about that you gonna do
something about that huh dick just gonna
take that ring and do nothing
take the ring and do not and I probably
get a figure out the puzzle down in the
basement damn it I'm gonna be here for
ages
ah bollocks bollocks all Ox
that means balls in English talk ah
am I sure there was nothing here I gave
you your stupid ring can I wear my ax go
I want to hack your hand off
now I'm not crazy you're crazy you're
all crazy for thinking I'm crazy I'm
crazy for thinking that you're thinking
I'm crazy because you like yeah
obviously you're not thinking right now
as I'm doing this because right now
right now you're not seeing it right now
cuz I'm recording this in the pact ain't
no future they're all gonna be zombies
and
mermaids mermaids you're gonna walk on
the land the whole world's gonna be
insane
except for me cuz I'm not crazy
bollocks
okay um okay why is there a painting Oh
huh six Oh what's this find this pen Oh
rub rub rub rub rub rub rub
aha [ __ ] ah what's this world's
greatest detective get off of there
[ __ ] ha ha I said huh
come on come up just a little more yeah
whoo whoo whoo Sh my fly
take that pyramid head suck on that okay
two three six five one four two three
okay wait two three six five one okay
one two three four five six okay okay
Donnie okay blondie flaw sir a choppa
Lani flosser a choppa Lani faster a
choppa okay
Lonnie far a choppa
yep bla me ha ray Cho far no pop oh come
on that was it no me far sorry Joe ba
there we go okay
I didn't sound good at all hey wait ring
of memories oh that stupid a whole
wanted a second ring by the way I'm
pretty proud of myself rigging that out
cuz usually I get stuck for a lot longer
not that I'm bad at games and whatnot
oh I thought that was something there I
thought something was happening there
why does this stupid hand need two rings
there's one ring not good enough oh
there we go
ha okay oh this looks good oh so it's
what I've always wanted a ladder up to
demon land good I like it oh hello
eyeball
man I do not remember those eyeballs and
then originally amnesia I'm I think they
were but hey locknut okay I know can go
up ha winner on the best rope what a
rope
what is this revolutionary device here
hmm I remember way back when I used to
try to make maps for the original
half-life and it blew my mind
ropes like that I thought I was like the
greatest map maker ever when I when I on
my own before I learned that everyone
else already knew how to do it you could
put the ladder the ladder thing that
made objects into ladders you could put
that on like anything and I put it on a
rope and made a rope go up and I thought
I was like a coolest thing ever and I
was super hot wait would
I thought I was like the greatest ever I
still think I'm the greatest ever but
just for different reasons now show of
hands who thinks up the greatest ever Oh
nobody oh yeah there they are
the psychiatrist called his name with a
caring voice he opened his eyes and
looked into the void how are you she
asked Anton he lied she knew he was
lying she knew what she was going to do
was she gonna do what was y'all what was
you gonna do oh ma did I scare you
good hmm morphine I didn't even use the
single drop of morphine I'm sorry I know
you're all probably let's see it won't
budge story of my life story of every
single amnesia custom Jerry why even
make them you're not gonna let him budge
even make them hey why is this get out
of there
did I just unleash some spectral horror
from another dimension by doing that
probably get out there no don't get on
there more get off of there less or wait
no get off of there less get off on
there get on layer let's let left earth
less lore less is more or less I don't
know I don't know I don't know I don't
know it's not gonna open well thank you
for being original about your disclaimer
that it won't open
I do appreciate your originality it
won't move oh how about that I'm so
surprised anything under you know oh
right actually I'm just being surprised
all over the place it won't move how
suspicious
nothing lock is broken
your face your face is broken me in your
face is broken okay I am actually before
I move on to here I am actually all at a
time thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos in
Ogden and as always I will see
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]